I was horrible wasn't that bad
did he you know
well you know
we didn't make me touch it no no don't
talk about it made me lick it stop it
I got a stitch going between my teeth no
Jack my head back and all [ __ ] stump
felt it out
when are you going to see it don't know
maybe thirsty
maybe Thursday get a little Powell Simon
and have you been to see Tommy yet [ __ ]
you okay so Tommy's got the virus bad
news big deal the gig goes on or hadn't
you noticed
swanny [ __ ] his leg up well top [ __ ]
but I could have been worse you know
hurt I know this couple of addicts
stupid wee lassies now feed him what
they need
little bits can't keep him happy the
punters line up favourite skull it's
easy money for me it's not a fortune I'm
thinking I should be going in it in here
less horse more skank this one is right
get clean get into dealing that's where
the future lies
set up some contacts get a huge lot of
smack punt it profit
what do you think [ __ ] you and I'll tell
you why mark I'm fed up to my back teeth
with losers and no helpers Draft packs
Kimmy's junkies and the like I'm getting
on with life what are you doing